Valkyrie King and killmonger who will
win in a three-way match no one has
asked about the three-way for some
reason well that sounded wrong no one
has asked about the uh
here at geek culture we've tested plenty
of chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this makes a Form and
Function helps the Titan Evo 2020 to
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co now congratulations on the
film thank you I've been watching you
since DIY people sorry to bother you oh
they can see movies and now upgrade what
makes each of these projects special to
you and how have they shaped your career
and your art oh thank well thank you so
much for asking I mean those those three
films that you just mentioned all are
films where I got to work with a
director and it was their directorial
debut and I think that's something that
I've gotten to do across my career so
many times and I feel with boots Riley
and Justin Simeon and now Michael B
Jordan I think to get to work with
somebody in their debut and and and on a
film that shows audiences that they're a
singular and important voice inside of
the inside of the industry is really
really exciting so I think that that is
something that is you know has has been
such a pleasure for me now I think the
Bianca is a particularly like important
character I mean she's not just like a
Donut's partner but she's in a way like
a form of representation for those who
are hard of hearing or deaf I think no
one would expect or imagine that a film
about boxing we have so much to say
about accessibility and disability have
you noticed any form of impact from your
portrayal of Bianca for me this time
around the thing that feels really
extraordinary we always knew or I always
knew and was an advocate for the fact
that there was only so far that we could
go with Bianca in terms of the
progression of her hearing loss frankly
because I think if we wanted to tell the
story of a character that is speaking
solely in ASL or a character that is
deaf that at this point it should be
played by a deaf actor and that is
something that I I felt really certain
about and and continued to advocate for
and so what feels exciting in this one
is that we have you know Mila Davis Kent
come in and and really offer that kind
of vital representation in the space and
that is such a such a gift and it was a
pleasure to get to continue to learn ASL
and I think I'm always interested in
characters that upend our expectations
inside of genre and particularly I think
when you think about big films like this
that travel globally like I'm speaking
to you there are people all over the
world that will be watching these movies
and I think the stories that we tell
tell us a lot about who we are I feel
like it's really important and and is
something I'm really proud of I am the
kind of creed but I'm also a big fan of
the superhero genre and I can't help it
as like I'm sure people have asked you
this before but like Michael Jonathan
and yourself are known as like Valkyrie
King and killmonger who will win in a
three-way match no one has asked about
the three-way for some reason well that
sounded wrong no one has asked about the
uh-huh
no one has asked about that uh Trifecta
as it were of Fighters people have asked
for some reason people are interested
about me and Jonathan in a match and I
have said that I would win now when
you're asking about this Trifecta of
characters I will also say that Valkyrie
will win
[Music]
foreign